emily is with us in Cincinnati hi Emily
how are you good how are you mr. Ramsey
better than I deserve what's up um well
my husband and I are having some trouble
Warren Beatty step number two and we
have a house that's vacant from his
previous marriage we owe $50,000 on it
we're working with your ELP it's been on
the market for about a year for 25,000
we haven't had any takers on it we took
out a couple signature loans when we had
it under contract and so we have enough
to make up that difference but now we're
trying to make it months and months now
that it's back on the market and the
original contracts make up the
difference the difference don't what
it's it's you know how you talk about
you oh you owe
oh you owe 50 yes and it's only worth 25
maybe if we can sell it for 25 what a
couple of offers 18 what I know it was
in the middle of doing a series of major
renovations on it so right now I'd only
have drywall hanging on the walls rather
than being mudded it's also in a
declining area of town that's drug
dealers across the street but I mean
it's worth fifty thousand fixed No it
might be worth 40 but their houses on
the street comparisons that have sold
for fourteen or twelve thousand dollars
and you owe 52 on what an FHA loan or
what yes and it also has his ex-wife's
name on the deed and the mortgage do we
have a bit no I guess she's willing to
sign the deed isn't she yeah I'm sure
you guys are covering the whole
difference right ye so you're going to
borrow the difference we did borrow the
difference and so now we're making
payments on a couple of signature loans
and and on the mortgage itself and the
money sitting there correct okay um well
what is the ELP saying or you think
you're gonna get another offer in yeah
he's gonna call we check in with him
about every
week and we thought another interest
we've had one offer for $18,000 cash but
at that point we were still pretty early
in the process so we let that one go
and then we had another interest in each
$2,000 I don't know what the magic is
between 18 but but we're not sure if we
should take 18 or run or sounds like it
sounds like this deal is about done I
mean it's this thing is going down and
it's going you know it's it's just
unraveling on you and so the you know
every every month you pay another set of
payments on the house itself and on the
on the others did you reduce the
mortgage by that amount yet no you
didn't tell you so that signature of
money's still sitting in the bank
sure sure so it's all a big strain yeah
Alex what's your household income about
15 well that's good news
okay yeah I think if you don't get it
moved pretty quick you probably need to
pay the signature loans off and until
you and then take them back out again
right okay if you you know if you don't
get all if you don't get an offer here
in the next week or two I'm gonna pay
those things off and not be paying
payments on money that's just sitting
there at 1% right okay you know we
weren't sure how long to wait it out I
mean I wouldn't wait it out a long time
a couple weeks maybe but I wouldn't do
it for months and on the end what
happens if we get another offer we're
not sure if we're gonna be able to get
the signature loans back why I'm not
sure it's just a concern even we would
be able to wreak Walla Fife or another
set of signature loans if we got an
offer well I don't know I mean you got
him the first time if something hasn't
changed I don't know why you wouldn't be
able to get them the second time okay
I would check with your banker somebody
made you a straight-up signature loan
that's pretty substantial so they saw
something just to say you know is there
any chance that this wouldn't be
available again because we may want to
do this again a little bit late
and see what they say okay and if they
give you any reason to be afraid then
maybe we do maybe we don't pay them off
right right and we can just barely make
all the payments works but we have like
$50 left over at the end of the month
yeah you have to tighten up your budget
and probably pick up some extra work it
sounds like or sell some stuff obviously
you're trying to sell this and get rid
of it but ouch what a mess
so yeah I'm taking 18 you know if we can
get the let's get some money in the bank
and let's get this thing done and get
rid of that first mortgage payment that
fitted the payment on the fifty thousand
and that opens up your life again you
still got the signature loans for you
know they're back in your debt snowball
then to try to clean this mess up oh I'm
sorry Wow
hey guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
enjoyed that video from the Dave Ramsey
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video three things
you should consider renting right over
here or click the link in the
description below